[Todd Field]  Long before steroids
and multi-million dollar contracts,
there was a truly independent ball club,
a bunch of guys who were hopeless dreamers
looking for a second chance.
In short...
the best kind of people.
[Carren Woods]  When we first heard
about Bing Russell,
there was this buzz about,
"Well, who's Bing Russell?"
[Field]  And he was in
The Magnificent Seven
and he's the sheriff on  Bonanza.
My dad got killed 126 times,
I think it was.
[Field]  Why would Bing Russell
come to Portland?
Bing was out to prove that
independent baseball could work.
[Bob Richmond]  And I think we charged Bing
$500 for the franchise.
[Kurt Russell]  So we started from scratch.
"We're going to have open tryouts."
"Show us for the fools that we are
coming from Hollywood."
[Frank Peters]  You'd expect maybe
40 or 50 people to show up,
and I think 300 showed up.
[Woods]  Guys who drove
clear across the country
and sacrificed this or sold this
just for the chance
to come and try out for the team.
I don't care about the money.
I just want to play ball.
[Field]  There was no press handlers.
There was no groomed image.
There were just these furry, hairy, funny,
great bunch of guys...
[bat cracking]
...and the things that happened
on the field were absolutely insane.
[bat cracking]
[Woods]  Organized baseball
didn't like Bing
and they did everything they could
to make sure Bing didn't win.
[bat cracking]
[Kurt]  He couldn't stand them.
They couldn't stand him.
Portland is the greatest
baseball city in the world.
[Field]  We broke attendance records
in the entire Minor Leagues that year.
[Rob Nelson]  We really emphasized fun.
[Richmond]  The fans loved it.
[Field]  I've never seen a ball team
and fans behave the way
they did with the Mavericks.
[Kurt]  He created the most successful team
in the history of Minor League Baseball.
[bat cracking]
"This is gonna be magic."